hello hello welcome to chess openings
explained it's me nick risco your
instructor for tonight and we are back
here live in the st louis chess club
studio
now the question that we're going to be
aiming to answer over the next probably
two months is are you a real
chess openings explained lecturer if you
don't have a 10 part series
that's what we're gonna be getting into
right now with part one of a series over
the scotch the scotch game gambit and
all other openings
falling
in that category so we're actually going
to be starting with
a lot of the sidelines first here
mainly tonight our focus is going to be
on third move deviations or
weird third move sidelines that black
can get into
after the opening moves
so let's get right into it
we have pawn to e4 pawn to e5
knight to f3
knight to c6 and pawn to d4 and this is
the scotch opening
uh so here the idea is uh
you're you're playing d4 you're going to
open it up um i guess the
the drawback to this compared to other
moves uh
i guess like bishop c4 or bishop b5 the
spanish and the italian openings is that
d4 is not as well prepared uh black can
just liquidate right away on d4
and white is going to not be as ahead in
development
and stuff like that so it's gonna be a
little bit slower just want to thank
phenol monkey for the sub here
all right so we have d4
and the first move we're going to be
looking at is uh probably one that's
very easily dealt with
is pawn to d5
uh here black is trying to create
complications in the center at the cost
of potentially losing this e-pawn and
the way that white punishes this is just
by snapping it off and we're going to go
with the knight here we're not going to
go with the pawn
uh mainly because black could probably
just take and get into
uh just an end game that isn't you know
horrible for them um maybe something
like knight to g5 here
and maybe even knight h6 just protecting
f7 and then we see a trade of pawns in
the center now
by by no means am i claiming that these
are the best moves for both sides but
white does have better after knight
takes e5 really the only way that black
can try to make progress here in the
center is if they trade knights black
does have this option of taking on e4
which has been growing in popularity
recently but this is pretty easily dealt
with
one way that white can reduce this
tension in the center is by playing
bishop to b5 pinning this knight to the
king and the only way to break this
tension is to play bishop d7
and after bishop to d7 white has this
nice move knight takes d7 not only
winning the bishop pair which can be of
some use in an open position but now
reintroducing the pin completely as now
if the knight moves the queen is
attacked and here white just simply
defends their center pawn
and if black continues developing white
can just castle safely and bishop to d6
is a good developing move but now white
has the time to go knight d2
and after black castles
one key idea white uh should remember
here is that they can actually play f3
uh we've been told time and time again
by a certain grandmaster
never play f3 or f6 but here it's
actually a pretty good idea to chip away
at
whatever center control black has left
here with their pawns and if they take
which i i think is probably the best
decision to go with
um then white can recapture with the
knight and white has this uh nice space
advantage here in the center the bishops
are open this other bishop can drop back
and point at the king side the knights
ready to hop in
i think all these moves are very natural
for white and shouldn't require too much
thought about
so they could take on e4 but i think
white's position is just super easy
i think the one that could potentially
give problems if white is unprepared is
knight takes e5
and d takes e5
and now black does best by capturing on
e4 offering up the trade of queens now
as white we should accept this our
opponent is offering us to give up his
castling rights we might as well take
advantage of that
but now knight c3 and white's already
putting pressure on the position this e
pawn is likely to fall
and if black plays something
supernatural like bishop to b4
white has this uh pretty nice line here
bishop g5 check and it's very important
that black chooses the correct move here
if black tries to play knight e7 with
the idea of developing this leads into a
completely lost position because now
white has castles with check
which breaks this pin the bishop had so
now after the king goes to e8
white can just take on e4 for free and
this bishop really has no purpose here
anymore and these king side pawns are
likely to roll forward
so black needs to be very careful they
they do need to play king e8 otherwise
they are going to be running into
castles along with check
uh but now here it comes without check
and black could capture on c3 if they
want to double up white's pawns but i
think it's a little bit more important
that they focus on their development so
i recommend bishop to g4
bishop to b5 check
and
now after c6 just drop the bishop back
to e2
you're likely to trade off at least one
set of minor pieces whether that is with
the bishop uh taking on c3 and you take
on g4 this is how you don't lose
material
or whether it's bishop takes e2 and
knight takes e2 and then this e pawn is
going to be a weakness forever
so i think here already move three
whenever black plays d5
pretty easy for white to get around
nothing too terribly sharp and
complicated
so that is our first sideline
the next one we're going to look at is
after e4 e5 knight f3 knight c6 d4
is knight f6 now this one does look very
natural for black i would not blame any
of my opponents playing this move it
looks very natural developing
but i think i feel like this is also
very easily remedied just by simply
pushing the pawn you push the pawn to d5
and now you're asking black hey where
are you going to put your knight that's
on c6 and it's not quite so clear at
first glance
um
you're also forcing black to move their
knight again so they're wasting time by
moving the same pieces over and over
again
and now we'll start getting into where
does the knight actually go
you cannot go to d4 even though it looks
good you're centralizing your knight you
are hanging upon after knight d4 knight
d4 or sorry ed4 and queen d4 you're just
giving up a pawn for free and now
white's queen is centralized there's no
way you can punish white for this
because your knight is no longer on b8
able to come to c6 and kick it
and really there's no pressure on e4 it
can easily be defended by bishop d3
knight c3 or even knight d2 f3 is even
possible if e4 faces any kind of
pressure at all
so knight d4 uh is a big blunder here
you do have other moves though that do
require some consideration knight b8 is
a popular one and probably a good try
for black here
if they find themselves in this position
white can take on e5 with the knight but
they do need to be aware that they can't
just expect to win this pawn completely
for free you are gonna have to do a
little bit of defending of your center
here because queen e7 not only hits the
knight but if you move the knight away
you're actually going to be losing the
center pawn so it would actually be a
trade of pawns instead of you just
winning on e5
so
i would recommend
defending your knight with queen to d4
again it's not
any danger because the pawn on d5 stops
this knight from coming to c6
and now after something like pawn d6 the
point is kicking the knight so they can
take on e4
you have this in between move here very
important develop while you can bishop
b5 check you get this piece out of the
way and you're getting ready to castle
uh and here the best move for black is
actually king 2 d8 if you don't play
king to d8 and let's say you block with
your other knight white already has a
fantastic position because their knight
that is attacked on e5 can trade itself
off for whatever is on d7
so
they can't exactly just block on d7
white is going to end up having a very
nice center extra pawn
if there's ever a block so they do have
to go king d8 just to
avoid any material deficiencies
and now
white can retreat the knight and black
will capture with the queen i do want to
point out it is not possible for black
to capture with the knight
even though it does look good
it looks a bit more natural avoiding
putting the queen out in the center
and black may have the idea hey i don't
want to trade queens i want to keep
queens on the board so i can generate
chances later but this is actually a
blunder
and not for the most clear move it's
actually castles and what the point of
castling is is that you want to play
rook to e1
you're pinning the knight to the queen
and let's say the knight moves let's say
knight f6
or
uh how about this this may even
illustrate the purpose even better if
knight g5
rook e1
well okay this doesn't work uh i'm now
realizing there's a flaw on my line
let's say this move doesn't exist i'm
just just trying to illustrate a purpose
here
uh if black tries to go for a queen
trade here there's also this mate it's
uh the opera mate the opera pattern
so
that's just for illustrative purposes if
they go knight g5 you should clearly
take with the bishop
but
just putting the rook on e1 is
definitely a major goal of whites trying
to pin the knight and
also get behind the queen for this mate
idea
i'm seeing a lot of people in the
comments section here
[Music]
see implicants is saying sometimes you
get a one pawn advantage and trade
everything
i i don't think that's how we're going
to be looking at it so in some of these
lines white does gain upon um the idea
isn't just to trade everything off
because then you won't have any pieces
left to help that one pawn promote
but our idea here is to use this extra
pawn for a space advantage or something
of the likes
okay so we went over why knight to e4
doesn't work and just some other lines
to illustrate this purpose if they go f5
trying to protect the knight this runs
into rookie one and if a6 there's
actually a very nice sacrifice rook
takes e4
f takes e4
and bishop to g5 pinning the queen to
the king defended by the knight and
white will actually come out on top here
despite two minor pieces being attacked
and sacrificing an exchange
if black decides to play c5 and attack
the queen instead this one's also pretty
easy to deal with you take on c6 with on
passant
and then after the pawn recaptures you
still have rook to e1 hitting the knight
and if they take the bishop well here
rook takes on e4 is going to be crushing
queen to d7 bishop to g5 check
and the last little trick here if they
block with f6 you can actually just take
on f6 with the bishop if the pawn takes
back you have this very nice fork
so this is all why
black must capture with the queen
otherwise castling just why has too much
peace activity but if black captures
with the queen and we go with a queen
trade here
this position is uh relatively balanced
uh we castle here as white and black can
play a6 and white can retreat the bishop
pretty much to anywhere
but i think bishop c4
is the idea trying to avoid this bishop
d3 met by knight c5
idea here so i think this is actually a
way for for black to play if they find
themselves in this situation knight b8
um white can enjoy a comfortable game i
don't think black poses any problems at
any point
uh what else does black have here
well
uh it looks like they have knight to e7
and i actually played a couple games
against uh other people here at the
chess club today just to see what they
would play and knight to e7 was
almost always the instinct
so this is a blitz game and your
opponent is ill-prepared knight u7
is probably the expected move
now after knight e7 you do get to
capture on e5
there is no queen e7 trying to put
pressure on the e file so you do get
this pawn
but in turn black will capture on e4
now here engines will recommend moves
like queen e2 or bishop d3 but one move
that i really like and one move that i
thought of that reminded me of my vienna
lecture
is queen to f3
and while again it's not the engine's
top choice the engine still likes it and
it has some trickiness
it's actually
not the easiest to defend with black
here
if you go with the natural knight to f6
well black could be facing problems
after knight c3
and already it's pretty hard to tell how
black is supposed to develop their
pieces
um if you go with this natural looking
d6
well black can resign after d6 you have
this very nice bishop b5 check coming in
on the diagonal
and suddenly you realize black is going
to be losing a lot of material either
their queen or i believe it's their rook
and a bishop
but if you look here
black if they block with the bishop
is met by bishop takes bishop and if the
knight takes there's a very nice
checkmate in one
if the queen takes on d7 then knight
takes d7 and suddenly you realize white
is just up a queen
and if you decide to block with
i guess you block with knight d7 first
this is still checkmate in one but if
you block with the pawn
well d takes c6 is the winning
continuation here after dc6 if they take
with the pawn
then knight takes c6 and you're going to
end up with this fork
um i guess bishop takes c6 is also
winning because you have queen take c6
resulting in this idea
um
and yeah if they decide to play
something like
i don't know
they can try a6 getting the bishop but
this is met by either c takes b7 where
you're going to take the rook and
promote or just c7 check and you're
going to win a queen this way so lots of
problems for black now
d6 is not forced by any means there are
still moves here but there's a lot of
moves here that also make mistakes like
b6 if you're trying to develop your
light squared bishop this way runs into
pawn d6 where it hits the knight and
your queen is hitting this rook uh this
is definitely one of those puzzle rush
tactics
okay so if d6 and b6 don't work we can't
develop our light squared bishop let's
focus on developing our dark square
bishop well you can't play g6 because
you hang your knight so
really there's only one way to develop
and that is knight to g6 this is
probably the only way to develop without
losing material and try and stay on pace
with white's
white's development here
so knight g6
very easily met with knight takes g6 and
now hg6
and white doesn't have to do anything
special here their pawn on d5 is clearly
well defended by the knight and the the
queen so even a move like bishop d2
is
perfectly fine uh you might run into
bishop c5 it's no problem the queen's
protecting and now white just castles
and white enjoys very natural
development so this bishop can come to
c4 maybe even d3
and white also has nice space with this
pawn on d5 while black is still going to
be struggling with
how they're going to be developing this
light squared bishop
so
i think that uh
this this idea here by black is refuted
with knight e7 and then after you take
they take on e4
what are some other ideas black has
really there's only one other idea and
that is knight to a5 putting the knight
on the edge of the board
and you know what because we're live i'm
going to ask the audience what move do
you think is the best in this position
may not be uh clear
the uh engine number one move is
definitely
not was not one of my candidates i wanna
see what uh the audience can come up
with here
potassium one says hi i'm now 2100
radiated player in lead chess
tell me how do i improve my rating
well it's going to be uh probably
tactics and end games
i know whenever i was 2100 at least in
classical
i studied my end games and
my openings as well and was able to add
a couple hundred more elo on top of that
no guesses from the audience
alright well if we don't have any
guesses from the audience
all right someone's using an engine or
they've looked at this position before
uh but yes the uh the move here the top
move
is a three now what is the idea of a3
this looks like it does nothing to
contribute to white's position right
what piece is this developing how does
this like influence our center at all
why are we not just taking this pawn on
e5
well that last question we can answer uh
already from looking at our other line
if knight takes e5 we do run into some
tricks with queen to e7
but here white actually throws in this
move a3 with a very clear threat b4
trapping the knight so if black decides
all right i'm going to go d6 solidify my
center open up my bishop well all right
i'll just uh attack your knight he has
nowhere to go
and uh i get a free horse
so after white plays a3 this actually
prompts black to play only one move and
that is b6 there really is no other way
to save your knight and the point is
that if b4 right away then you can tuck
the knight on b7
so this is the point of b6
and i have to be honest after b6 i
didn't really know what to recommend it
seemed like masters or maybe it wasn't
even master games but
uh it seems like here most people who
reached this position played knight b to
d2
even though the engine heavily prefers
moves like knight takes e5 and knight c3
so i was looking around
and i'll show you both of the lines
because they're very similar it's the
same idea
but we'll take a look at knight b to d2
because this is what most people play
and it really depends on where you want
your bishop
but after knight to d2
now black does have time to play d6
and after d6 we can play b4
kick the knight back to b7
and our idea here is to go bishop a6 and
what this does is it prevents black's
bishop from developing this really ties
down black's pieces you have this knight
on b7 that can't go anywhere this bishop
on c8 is defending this knight so
uh black's really hurting here on the
queen side as far as the the moveability
of their pieces
so now like queen d7 trying to just get
some kind of play maybe queen a4 is an
idea
but after queen d7 i most people play
queen e2 here and then knight to d8 so
creating this square for the knight
offering a trade of bishops
but here white doesn't have to take um
it can seem very natural just to take on
c8 and then rook takes c8 now black's
ready to play c5
i highly recommend not doing this
and the point isn't that you know
you just want to keep the bishop just to
keep a bishop
but if you retreat this bishop back to
d3 just solidify your center
white has a lot of space with this pawn
on d5
this bishop is keeping the position
solid whereas black's bishop
what is it doing it can't go to a6
because of the bishop it can't
okay it can go to b7 but it's not doing
anything on b7 it's hitting the uh these
pawns in the center and will barely have
any influence
if you're going to go bishop b7 it's so
you can play c6 and chip away at the
center
but even this idea which we will see in
just a second
um
is just uh
met with c4
um
let's see in the chat
uh someone's saying bishop b5 looks like
it's winning unfortunately it's not they
can block with c6
so they do block with c6 you can take
with the pawn it can be met with i
believe knight takes
but something like bishop a4 or again
just retreating you can take if you want
but knight takes c6 and black is doing
just fine you start opening up this
position and now this knight that was
stuck on d8
is starting to get into the game
but uh very nice observation
um this is something you could try try
to do
um
but yeah queen e2 knight d8 bishop d3
and now black finishes development and
once we look at this position we realize
white is just dominating on the queen
side here with the space
and again if uh black tries to go c6 we
would just meet it with c4
and really the only other idea black has
here is to try and play a5 and break on
the queen side and if they ever play a5
trying to chip away you just play rook
b1 and defend and yeah black gets this a
file but it's not really doing much for
them and if they try to just go like
rook a2 you have rook b2 offering the
trade and white is happy here now your
rook is going to get to a1
so i think um
this
might be tough for black to play i think
it's doable
but it might be tough
i'll also show what happens if the
knight goes to c3 again it's pretty much
the same idea except here with knight to
c3 instead of trying to go like bishop
to d or sorry b2
um now the bishop is likely to go to g5
so i think it's really up to you on
where you want your bishop to go
if you want your bishop to come here to
g5 go knight c3 if you're looking more
at bishop to b2 then i believe knight b
to d2 is better
but yeah here if they go d6 you kick the
knight again and bishop to a6
um and both sides complete their
development
pretty natural moves from both sides
again not trading off the light squared
bishops
and i think this is fine for white and
engines just saying white is white is
doing great mainly because
black can't really do anything on the
queen side here
so
that is uh
here third move knight to f6
and that pretty much sums it up d5
really they only have those options with
the knight
okay our next sideline
is going to be
3d6
okay so this can also be reached from
affiliador move order
so if you play knight f3 and your
opponent plays d6 you can still go d4
and you can reach the same position
after they play knight to c6
now here you do have a few different
options uh one that people may be
looking at right away is pawn takes e5
and what this is going to do is trade
into an end game this is completely fine
and playable
but i find the end game to actually be
pretty okay for black in this position i
don't think there's
anything
you know
i don't think there's any major problems
for black other than they're a move
behind
so you do have this option if you want
to just outplay your opponent in an end
game
otherwise you have two other options
you can go bishop to b5 and what this
does is it transposes into a uh
well it's hard to say if this transposes
into the steinitz of the rui lopez or if
the roy lopez transposes to this line in
the scotch but you have bishop to b5
and here the point is after takes takes
and bishop to d7
you can go knight c3
and black's most played idea here is g6
trying to fiend keto the bishop
and i don't think white's moves are too
terribly difficult here
bishop to e3 developing almost like a
yugoslav setup from the dragon and now
after bishop g7 queen d2 no need to
worry about f3 there's no knight trying
to come to g4
you have knight f6
now the knight can be trying to go to g4
but white has some moves that can gain
them a little bit of time starting with
bishop takes c6 doubling up the pawns if
the bishop takes now you can play f3
because e4 is under fire you stop the
knight from coming to g4 and trying to
trade off for this attacking bishop
but most commonly played is b takes
and bishop to h6 already trying to trade
off this nice defending piece so you see
castles
trade of bishops and after castles long
i think white's position is completely
fine you have two knights that are
centralized black's structure is
weakened
and white can play something like f3
they also have h4 h5 trying to crash
through on the king side
um
yeah you play this kind of like
almost like a dragon
but that that should be good for white
as well uh but i think my main
recommendation is actually going to be
this idea if you saw it in the uh the
chesable scotch course here
um but d5
and i think d5 is a rather forcing line
which should be easy to remember after
d5
this knight does have a decision to make
where does it go
and again most commonly this knight is
going to go back to e7 you can't go to
d4 again just because of takes takes and
takes and you're down to pawn
so you go back to e7
and there's a couple tries here uh white
should go c4 solidify the center
and i think black has actually two tries
here
um
which in i think the course i was
looking at said knight f6 is the main
move and it is we'll take a look at that
this is definitely the most played
but
again i was doing some games against the
members of the club earlier today and f5
was tried a couple times
and i thought this was very interesting
it almost looked like a very real threat
that uh black is actually just expanding
on the king side and getting completely
fine development
but
i think it's very interesting here
we have knight to c3 defending the pawn
knight to f6 attacking the pawn again
and
maybe a little counter intuitive
you should play e takes f5
and if bishop takes f5
you start with this move h3
and the point of h3 is to stop anything
from coming to g4 and hurting your
position
and after
h3 black has like
two id not really not even two ideas one
idea was g6 to go bishop to g7 but
already white has this pretty awesome
looking g4 and after a bishop to d7
uh bishop to g2 computers are already
giving this an evaluation of plus two
i think personally that might be a
little
ambitious
um because i think it's easy for white
to play passive moves and slip into a
more balanced position
but for example bishop to g7 is met with
knight to g5
uh first off one idea is to go to e6
but also you're looking to go to e4 and
trade off one of your knights for this
knight on f6 i think this knight on f6
is probably black's best minor piece and
trading off one of your knights for it
shouldn't hurt your position if black
tries to kick it with h6 you just go
knight ge4
and uh
the idea that was tried in the game
was uh knight to g8
and here white can go with c5 start
smashing through the center and this may
start to look like a king's indian
defense gone wrong
this is something that black wants to
avoid at all costs we see this trade and
now
you can't just take on c5 because of
bishop g6
um
it's very weakening for black don't play
like this please
instead if you are playing like this as
black first off reconsider your openings
but if you have this position play c6 uh
and after white plays bishop to e2
uh takes on d5 very important take with
the pawn use this pawn to cement this
structure in the center and secure your
space advantage
and this should be enough to counter
this f5 idea by black black is going to
have a bit of a hard time getting this
dark square bishop developed and
sometimes may even need to castle long
so f5 very interesting do i think it's
great
i don't think so
[Music]
so we're going to look at knight f6 this
is
more popular it's more solid we go
knight c3 defending our pawn on e4
and
again two ideas here
uh we have knight to g6 which we saw in
some of our other lines trying to
develop this bishop to e7 and we also
have pawn to g6 trying to develop this
way
now g6 actually works a little bit
better here
earlier rather than later and it
basically goes into a king's indian
defense but i think white is further
ahead in their plan for instance after
g6 white can play c5 right away which is
like usually a break they're saving for
the middle game in a king's indian
defense
but they just hit black with it right
away
and
there's there's a couple things here one
if bishop g7 right away you can take on
d6 and then you go queen
queen a4
and either minor piece if either minor
piece blocks you move the queen to b4
and you're putting pressure on b7 and d6
um whereas if queen a4 and queen d7
loses instantly because of bishop b5
so
bishop g7 could run into some problems
um definitely some pressure on the queen
side instead i think they should take on
c5 which
is a little unfortunate because this is
what white wants
and after d takes c5 bishop to e3 you're
just putting pressure on the pawns
and while knight d7 looks like it's
going to hold white is going to get some
nice play here starting with bishop to
c4
and after bishop to g7
uh i think this move d6 is pretty nice
you're pushing the pawn forward
attacking the knight the knight doesn't
really have anywhere great to go if it
goes to c6
um it's actually losing for black
because of bishop f7 and if the king
takes the point is knight g5
king e8 and then knight e6
kind of trapping the queen here and if
you move the queen to safety well now um
well first there's knight d5 hitting it
again and if they take your knight you
win the queen
or even just knight c7 right away should
be good enough
so
here black really should take
and after taking there is queen d6 and
now both of these pawns are going to be
facing massive pressure from white's
knight and the queen
plus this bishop on e3
black can try castling getting out of it
but white is going to get a lot of
pressure after castling queenside
getting a lot of pressure on this d-file
um now here queen e8 might be an idea by
black trying to break this pin so you
can move the knight but this is actually
met with knight to b5 which is pretty
strong going to c6 and i don't see a
great way to stop this
so
rather than queen to e8
we have knight to c6
and now the only move that will secure
white a huge advantage
is knight to d5
and there's quite a
quite a bit of ideas here um but i'll
give an illustrative line of knight to
b6
looking for the queen trade you give it
to them
and now uh knight to e7 is actually
going to give you the material
advantage rather than just a positional
advantage
king to f8 you have knight c6
and
now you get this pawn on c5 and here
black's structure is
not exactly fun
uh white does have the better structure
and after king e8 and bishop to b3 oh
boy i did put a lot of arrows on here
you'll see all of white's pieces are
very good the bishops are very active
this knight is putting pressure on e5
whereas black's knight has nowhere to go
and their bishop is blocked in by their
own pawn
so
it's not a huge surprise that the engine
prefers white here
um okay what else do they have
um
to do
not this g6 idea but rather knight g6
this is what we're going to get into
all right so we see knight g6
and the point is getting the bishop to
e7
so here the way that i think white
should
should go um
most players have played bishop to e2
this is by far the most common move
but it's not very ambitious after bishop
to e2 you're not really posing any
threats to your opponent
yours kind of you know developing which
isn't bad but is very passive and if you
keep playing normal moves
then black can equalize rather quickly
and the game will follow kind of the
style of a king's indian defense
black is doing just fine here with a
balanced position
i think more ambitious is h4 right away
you're threatening h5 which is going to
hit the knight yet again and black has
already spent you know however many
tempo moving the knights they really
can't afford to allow h5
uh so they play bishop to g4
which
not only introduces this pin but it also
stops white from playing h5
and
in the trustable course that i was
looking at i was recommending bishop to
e2 but i think i found a little
improvement here
um is actually going g3 first
uh you don't need to play bishop e2 the
pin is nothing to worry about the knight
is defended
and after g3
black's best move is bishop to e7
looking to castle
uh now you play bishop to e2
and
really what black has to do
is um if they try c6
you can develop like normal i think this
transposes to to the line and trustable
but um
if they try a6 i think is the idea that
they can go with
uh you also have this idea of knight to
h2
forcing a trade of light squared bishops
if they don't take the trade and they go
back to d7 h5 is going to get through
this isn't exactly fun
so takes on e2 and now queen takes on e2
and what white has accomplished here is
they've traded off
a
a bit of an annoying piece their light
squared bishop because with all these
pawns on light squares in the center you
don't want that bishop on the light
squares your pawns are going to obstruct
it
and i think white has guaranteed
themselves
uh probably the best minor pieces they
can have and black is left with this
bishop that's on the same color as their
center pawns
so that's what white has accomplished
here
and i think black can get away with h6
or
probably even castling
well maybe not castling because of h5
but something like c6 or h6 should be
[Music]
playable for black but this position
does lend itself to white and uh here we
actually after queen e2 does follow a
game um back from 1997 between two 22
hundreds uh bureau martisca
but i did want to show this because
uh this is also a line you can get from
the phillidor you can get similar
positions from the steinitz
but i did want to show that
you do have this extra option of d5
okay
our last set of sidelines here is
actually going to all come from the same
third move but they're going to be um
three different systems
uh so here we're going to be looking at
uh on move number three black captures
on d4
not with the pawn because that's the
main line we're looking at side lines
tonight they're going to capture on d4
with the knight
and
some would say this is already a big
mistake by black it's not a mistake in
the way the computer would evaluate it
but black definitely has better options
than just trading this knight right away
and the first system we're going to look
at for white is just capturing on e5
this seems very natural we just lost a
pawn we're going to gain it back and now
we have tempo on the knights black has
to respond to this
and almost universally uh black plays
knight to e6 here
it should be noted if they go to c6
white should take
if d takes then you get into an end game
where white can castle
um but if b takes then knight c3 should
be slightly better for white
but okay 96
and i got to be honest this one was the
one i was struggling the most to try and
find a way to punish and refute
and
i i have to come and be honest i i could
not find
just this awesome smashing system for
white
but i did find a pretty easy system for
white that
can't really be refuted
is a g3
after g3 here um
you're looking to go bishop to g2
knight to c3
and our sample line here black plays d6
hitting the knight opening up the bishop
you go knight to d3
the point is that way you leave this
open for your bishop in the future
and now knight f6 hitting the pawn
no worries you just play bishop to g2
defending
and c6 c6 might look a little strange
but
black may want to break with d5 one day
and you're also you know if white can
never get e5 through kind of shutting
down this diagonal in advance so c6
makes a bit of sense here
uh white can continue with knight c3
bishop to e7
and castles by both sides
and
this is pretty pretty balanced but
unfortunately again i have to say i
think this position
um
it seems pretty reasonable for black
i don't think you can just
crush this
as white
but i do need to show it because uh
i think
it is important now
after knight takes d4 this is not you
know the only move knight takes e5
can lead to a balanced position but i'm
here to show you two other options that
you have
um we have the lolly variation and the
napoleon gambit so we're gonna we're
gonna go over the lolly variation real
quick very short and then we're going to
get into the very very exciting napoleon
gambit
i'll give it just a second here
okay
knight takes on d4
knight takes on d4
now when i first started chess when i
was a novice i didn't even know what
openings were this is what i would play
naturally
you know my opponent just took on d4
with the knight i'm going to take with
the knight or
um you
also mention this whenever we talk about
fourth move alternatives you can reach
um the same position after pawn takes
knight takes and then knight takes again
you have queen takes d4
um so same position two different move
orders there's a sideline on the third
move and a line on the fourth move but
they get you to the same position your
queen ends up on d4
normally when the queen is on d4
it's not good because it can be punished
by the move knight on b8 to c6
i don't think i need to explain to this
audience
why
white is able to get away with queen d4
here
now black has
two tries
i'll go over a third here knight f6
knight f6 looks very natural you're
developing on the king side you're gonna
follow it up with some bishop move maybe
and then castle
but this is punished immediately by pawn
to e5 asking the knight where are you
going
and black does have this response c5
attacking the queen
and if you don't know your preparation
as white this can definitely throw you
for a loop probably catch you off guard
but all you do
is queen e3
now this does allow knight d5 they're
hitting your queen again
you need to go um
like queen f3 or really any queen move i
think
and now knight to b4
and you're starting to ask you know
black black is moving this night a lot
but they do have a big threat taking on
c2 and winning an exchange
but here
bishop to c4
first um developing your piece and
threatening mate
with queen takes f7
pawn d5
pawn takes on d6 the on passant rule
and now queen f6 to stop the checkmate i
think white has a very nice continuation
with queen e3
bishop e6 to block
and bishop b5 check
the knight goes back to c6 because
otherwise your king would move and you
wouldn't be able to castle
and now
white can capture on c5 and i think this
is definitely better white is up what is
it two pawns in this position d6 is
let's be honest probably going to fall
but having the advantage of a pawn
is definitely
uh definitely gives some insurance for
your position
but knight f6 i don't think is is good
uh there is d6 here
and you can go knight c3 and knight f6
comes now now you can't play e5 because
d6 was played
so continue with bishop f4
i think the most played move here is
bishop g5
but the reason i'm recommending bishop
f4 is because this also mirrors some of
the lines i believe i suggested in my
philidor videos
and the position is actually going to
look
very similar to an exchange philidor
so
that's why i recommend this setup here
kind of looking like a yugoslav attack
again
ideas of g4 and h4 maybe going bishop c4
trading off the bishops shouldn't be a
problem for white
and you can go from here but i think
this is very pleasant for whites
but there is one more line that
at least when i checked in chess base uh
it was one of those hot moves that are
up and coming
and it is knight to e7
and the point of knight to e7
is to make up for the fact this knight
isn't on b8 is it's trying to go to c6
and hit the queen
but white does have some time so take
advantage of the time develop your piece
and now after knight c6 you just you
move the queen e3 again now knight b4
comes and
it's not like the knight one to d5 and
it hit the queen and the queen moved now
black is threatening to take on c2 and
not win a rook they're trying to win the
queen
so you have to do something about this
and you should go queen to e2
the queen defends on c2
and now black goes bishop to e7 and
white can continue with bishop e3
black should go d6 trying to get out
their light squared bishop on one of
these squares
uh and now white will have the time to
play a3 and kick the knight away
and now you can castle queenside
black castle's king side
but now i think white's position is
slightly better than what we just looked
at with what looked like an exchange
philidor
now this is starting to look a little
bit more aggressive with this pawn on f4
you might be looking at playing e5 in
the future
and ideas of g4 and h4 are still
possible
um like i should mention
i'll say black plays a waiting move
h4
like if they ever fall for taking this
it's winning right away because of queen
h5
if the bishop moves then it's checkmate
so
there are some very nice tricks here for
white
and i think this covers the lolly
variation i i can't think of any other
big moves by black that deserve
any recognition here
so we're going to move on to
probably one of my new favorite lines in
chess
the napoleon gambit i went down a rabbit
hole with this one
and honestly this line probably deserves
a chess openings explained video of its
own
um
i was going through and it looked like
the theory
there's actually like
not much theory here but i was doing
some engine analysis
and playing some lines against one of my
co-workers here
and there's quite a few only moves that
both sides need to know
so we'll get our scotch here and they
take on d4 we're going to take on d4
with the knight and after they take back
with the pawn
we're not going to take on d4 with the
queen
instead we're going to play bishop to c4
and this is known as the napoleon gambit
and this opening gets its name
from a game between napoleon bonaparte
versus one of his generals back in 1818
now
in that game
black decided to go bishop c5
and this is one of the first ideas of
the napoleon gambit is that if they go
bishop c5 white is immediately winning
after bishop f7
king takes on f7 and queen h5
forking the king and the bishop
now
in that game
uh napoleon did not play
bishop f7
so i'm not going to go through that game
actually
but feel free to look it up yourself
i just think it was a very very messy
game and definitely suspicious
but um i was doing some looking around
and there's a couple ideas black can
have
first off uh let's take a look at queen
f6 queen f6 holds on to the pawn
uh develops the queen and you can't
really punish this i don't think i think
after castles
and knight e7 after c3 and knight c6 i
think this position is pretty balanced
white is slightly better
because you take on d4 here
and after queen takes d4 you play
something like queen c2
i think this is fine for either side
queen f6 is probably a legit move that
you can play
um
but i guess there there's two other
moves we should look at one is c5 trying
to hold on to the pawn with their own
pawn but here white doesn't really need
to do much
that's special the castle
black plays d5
trying to
break up this center here but white can
just take
bishop d6
and c3 trying to get them to take and
recapture with the knight to develop
further
if you play rook e1
looks very natural
it's actually just met by knight e7 and
black is ready to castle
um i don't think
i i would prefer to play rookie one and
force black to
block i think i would rather have them
need to spend a move to block anyway
because
i guess the tempo you gain by moving
your rook
black gains it back by developing their
knight
so that's why i'm recommending c3
now knight e7 and you can take on d4
after they take on d4 queen takes
and
after black castles i think white is
just a healthy pawn up i don't see
any crazy way black can try and win this
back right away
i guess there's like queen a5 in the
future but that can be met with knight
c3 i think this is just um
i mean ic3 comes first so i think this
is just a
a nice position for white healthy pawn
the the last idea
this is
this is where i
went down the slippery slope
d5
d5 is again trying to
muddy the waters a little bit and i
think white should take with the bishop
white can take with either but i think
taking with the bishop it's a bit nicer
and
okay if black tries to hit the bishop
you just retreat the bishop back to b3
and natural development should get you
far enough in the game
we have
moves like knight d2 trying to develop
the knight queen f3 it looks like you're
blocking the knight but you're trying to
go knight e4
um
getting
the bishop pair
and after a5
white's white has a game you play sorry
not a3 you can play a4 here and be fine
uh develop the bishop
somewhere i think d2 and then get your
rooks in the center this is pretty
pretty straight forward if they play c6
the real trouble comes when they play
knight f6 because now they're
threatening to take on d5 and win their
pawn back
or maybe
some some ideas of taking on e4 combined
with queen e7 it's a little slow for
that plan but it exists
and here white should be content with
taking the pawn
all right that was easy we just take the
pawn we're good that's it
unfortunately that's not the case
black does want to try and get their
pawn back and d5 is going to be their
target for the next couple of moves
mainly because the bishop can't move
um
if this bishop moves
uh the queen hangs
um
so okay c6 looks very natural uh this is
actually a blunder c6 trying to get the
the bishop fails to bishop f7
and if the king takes you win the queen
or if king e7
well now you just trade queens and after
f3 white is just in a winning end game
they're up two pawns absolutely no
reason why they should lose this
so okay if c6 doesn't work how are we
going to put pressure on d5
we go bishop to e6 and again you cannot
capture because you would hang your
queen
so knight to c3
just reinforcing d5 reinforcing e4
and now we're met with c6 because now
there's no bishop to
f7
and
now white has to decide what to do
you have two options here
one which
i guess is fine
i'm not a big fan of it is queen a4
just pinning the pawn but now knight
takes d5 and after ed5 bishop d5 and
castles
bishop e6
um black is the one with the bishop pair
and it is a fairly open board and the
pawns are pretty symmetrical
so i think having the bishop pair is a a
nice
advantage here for black now white does
have the move you can start with like
rook d1
this is fine but again i i hardly think
black has any problems
so rather than queen a4
a bit sharper is bishop to g5
and after bishop to g5 i think both
sides need to start
paying attention and being accurate
black should go bishop to e7
if they take the pawn right away
i think white is doing just fine after
e5 this knight is pinned
and if you try and go bishop e7
then white is going to be winning after
pawn takes bishop takes
you can just trade on f6
and black structure
is not a structure this is just a bunch
of of targets as far as i'm concerned
um
or if they take with the pawn then
bishop to e3 and again
these are just targets it's not a pawn
structure
they're not helping each other out
so
you can't really take on d5
so bishop to e7
after bishop to e7
let's see what do i have here in my
notes
we have castles
so castle's long you're putting more
pressure on the d file
and here
there there's two moves that black has
there's queen a5
and after queen a5 there's two options
that white has
the first option
is to uh bail out with like queen a4
not in this position i don't believe
but you take on f6 first bishop f6
e5
bishop g5 check f4
and bishop takes f4
queen f4 cd5 uh this is where they have
the option they can bail out with queen
i4 and just get like a equal end game
or they can play king b1 and keep this
alive keep the queens on the board so
this is one idea
um if they go queen a5
the other idea black has
instead of going queen a5 right away
uh probably more critical
is taking on d5
and
in this position statically
white is down a piece
but we're going to get it back
the only move here is ed5
uh after e to d5
this is similar to like one of those
knight d5 sacrifices in the night or
and
black cannot capture on d5 if they
capture with the queen thank you for the
queen
if they capture with the bishop
uh you take on f6 they take on f6
and queen a4 check
and this piece is falling
so you will get your minor piece back
and white is up a pawn
and now after some moves by black
you see like g6 white has this idea of
h4
and h5
and
just run the pawn all the way down to h6
why don't you after king h8
king b1 just trying to get away from any
possible checks
queen d6 you can trade
and we'll see that we actually get into
a
losing
uh rook and the game white is up a pawn
this pawns on h6 trapping the king
it's gonna be relatively simple to get
these rooks to the seventh rank
so bishop takes d5 won't work
at the same time knight takes d5 won't
work because this will also lead to a
losing rook and the game
after bishop e7
and now if knight e7 this is meant by
queen takes g7
you're attacking the rook you're
attacking the queen you cannot save both
and if rook g8 trying to trade queens
well i'm going to take your queen and
laugh and say check
so queen takes e7 is forced because of
this and now knight takes d5 bishop
takes d5 and now instead of taking right
away you take on g7 hitting the rook
hitting the bishop you're going to be
winning material
rook f8 to save the rook is met with
rook d5
and now
rook e5 is a threat supported by the
queen
so black must play f6
and met by a queen trade rook to e1 king
f7 and rook d7 white is killing black
king g6 and take on b7 is just disaster
so many extra puns
so
what does black do
they can't capture on d5
they're going to go for some counter
play queen to a5
and after queen to a5
i believe a nice continuation for white
is bringing the rook towards the center
this is exactly like our classical night
lord
in where again
if black decides to try and capture
well we run into some big problems
because of this pin the uh the position
here just is not good for black queen
takes f6 is possible knight d5 is
possible there's so much so many ways to
win
um
so that being said black shouldn't
capture on d5 with the bishop however in
this position they do have knight takes
d5 which is one of their only moves
actually the only move to continue
and here
white's only move to keep an advantage
is queen g7
this has the exact same ideas we've been
talking about it hits the rook
you're looking to take on d5 and if
bishop takes rook takes e7 should be
winning
so black needs to castle
get the king out of the center defend
the rook on h8
but now there is rook takes d5 a couple
things going on with this move
um
first knight takes c3 doesn't look too
friendly
second after rook takes d5 you're taking
the defender of e7 uh so it's like
giving up a rook for two pieces and
black captures back if they capture with
the bishop
this is just lost after bishop takes e7
rook takes e7 is not lost
if rook takes e7 there is bishop to e6
trapping the rook back here
uh and what is it
i guess you go queen f6
and black starts getting active pieces i
guess
uh but taking with the bishop does keep
up the pressure because you're hitting
the rook
and after moving the rook to e8
queen to e5 protecting you're going to
be winning this bishop back
this uh
this should be just winning and it is so
they can't take with the bishop they
have to take with the rook
now you take on e7
and rook to e8 is mandatory you have to
keep up the pressure you have to stay in
time with white's development and
activity so rookie hitting the bishop
making white react is the way to go
it should also be mentioned you you
definitely cannot play knight d5 because
it hangs checkmate
so don't be greedy don't take the rook
defend your piece move it out of danger
and now rook f5 is an idea hitting the f
pawn you can just play f3
and i was going to end my analysis here
but i asked myself what is
you know does black have any threats
here and black can continue the game
with b5 and the idea is going b4 hitting
the knight and after the knight moves
coming in with the queen and the bishop
so
white does have to respond to this
um b3 is good
this is playable it's still
much better for white
but i wanted to give myself the world's
biggest headache so i started analyzing
rook takes e6
and taking with the rook is uh not good
for black because of queen f8 the king
is forced to the seventh rank and now
you take on f7 so white gets another
pawn
and after king d6 bishop e7
white will end up winning an exchange
so
uh they can't really take back with the
rook i was looking uh they have to take
back with the pawn which looks a little
scary at first because now this queen
does have more influence over the board
in general it keeps black's king stuck
to the back rank so
here there's also this tactic
queen f7
hitting the rook and if the rook simply
moves you have queen to e6 picking up
the other rook this rook is being hit
that's just winning for
for white so black must uh give back an
exchange
and white should take the rook with
check
and after just a couple more moves here
blocking with the queen
i didn't want to trade queens this is
just uh it lends itself to black
but this should be
a draw
or at least very balanced um
but queen takes b5 is probably white's
only try left
and after queen d4 by white
i think queen to e8
king b7 queen e7 and you have to move
the king back you can't uh do anything
with the queen you hang your queen uh
queen's also busy defending the rook
so i think here
uh this position has never been reached
but it looked like there were a lot of
only moves
and i thought this was very exciting i
would love to see this played in the
game but i i believe
this position
should be a draw
i think black is active enough
but computers are lending themselves
towards white and it looks like um
i mean white oops white does still have
a few ideas with playing a like a 3
b3
but this probably deserves way more
analysis than i can give it for our
lecture here we are 10 minutes over
but this is it
this is our our first part of many parts
to the scotch game here's our third move
sidelines i hope you guys are excited
about this gambit as i am
um
and yeah if you guys have any questions
um i guess we'll we'll give it a little
bit of time here maybe two minutes for
any questions
but yeah
will i be covering the scotch gambit too
yes i will be covering the scotch gambit
uh i believe that's what we're going to
be looking at next week and then
the lecture after that we're going to be
looking at the infamous nachmanson
gambit
so we have a lot of fun exciting chess
coming up over the next couple weeks
here
so i want to thank everyone for coming
and checking out the lecture tonight and
we will see you next week